will what's up man hey can you hear me
we got you dude let's go back two weeks
you weren't on the show last week uh and
there was uh a big flush if you will big
liquidation two weeks ago if you had
been on this show
you were very not very bearish but you
were pretty bearish you you had a i
think a sense that hey things uh may be
going down here uh and most people say
oh that's nonsense he's just saying that
now whatever but literally he wrote a
newsletter like we have the information
uh so talk to us about what you were
thinking kind of two weeks ago right
before that big liquidation uh flush
before we start talking about what's
happening right now
sure yeah so um i just threw two little
excerpts in here for anyone um reading
the letter and
so i'll read them both they're both very
short so two weeks ago and for week 16
so this was two weeks ago uh the week of
thanksgiving i said for bitcoin the
short-term bearish case lies in the
derivatives data we are currently seeing
open interest as a percentage of market
cap unfazed by this recent drawdown in
addition to this funding seems
relatively unfazed as well as the
limited amount of long liquidations that
we've seen would not be would not be
surprised to see some kind of final
liquidation driven wick
and then last week um i kind of got even
more cautious seeing that we still
hadn't flushed any of oi i said oi
excluding cme as well as just the
perpetual swap oi
are both near all-time highs in both usd
and btc terms we've got a regime of
positive premium or funding which
essentially you're just showing the same
thing as well as long short ratios we're
at all-time highs with no reset as well
as the derivatives data shows a large
buildup of oi that will likely get
released at some point just not sure
exactly when and you know this happened
ended up happening on friday not saying
that i knew it was gonna happen friday
but and then i said you know we'd love
to see some kind of oi wipe out followed
by a regime of negative slash mixed
funding similar to uh what we saw in you
know post september of uh last year
heading into q4 so
you know what what i'm just trying to
get at here is not just to shill like my
call or whatever
but just just to say that you know we
were we were pretty uh you know uh
preempted for this move and if you kind
of know what to look for in the
derivatives data uh then you you would
have probably been pretty risk off um
you know derivatives if if you're not
paying attention to the derivatives data
you're really having a huge blind spot
because the pert market is the most
liquid product in the bitcoin market so
it has the most impact on the overall
you know price action for bitcoin
and so that's something that you really
need to be paying attention to and it
would have really costed you if you
hadn't been paying attention that over
the last couple weeks so when you think
about this uh
obviously we get the liquidations right
there's kind of price continues to fall
continues to fall i think on some
exchanges it went sub 30k uh for a very
short period of time but for most
exchanges it kind of went down around 40
42 000 whatever it was we came back uh
you know by monday kind of mid-40s uh
and we've been hanging around you know
maybe forty eight to fifty thousand
dollars how do you start thinking about
that event before we talk about what's
happening right now is that a uh market
structure type uh like liquidation
driven thing and people shouldn't read
into
um you know uh virus variants or any
other stuff going on like it was just
purely super illiquid market somebody
came in sold a bunch of bitcoin it
created a bunch of liquidations and
that's all there is to it
sure so um you know i think i think
you can look at this
there's several factors to everything
it's never just one clear-cut thing and
so
the way i the way i like to see this
first of all that um
that the
open interest is just almost like you
think of pressure and so that pressure
has to get released at some point um so
we had this large buildup of pressure
over the last month month and a half in
combination with that we had a lot of um
institutional flows that kind of slow
down uh and and part of that i think is
just because
it's the end of the year you know we
have these funds that are sitting on
massive unrealized gains and then we've
had all this macro uncertainty whether
it be you know talking about the fed
raising rates as well as uh you know the
i can i can't pronounce on the cron or
whatever kobe variant that they you know
whatever um you know that i think i
think these kinds of things or
especially the covet variant uh news i
think it was kind of just um you know
excuse for some of these funds to take
profit
because they're sitting on these large
you know unrealized gains so they're
saying hey look you know we don't want
to you know lose these unrealized gains
we have let's just go ahead and lock
this in for the year right because funds
are based on this yearly basis um and so
you know i think you're you're starting
to see some of that um and and you could
also kind of technically make an
argument that you'll see those flows
reverse heading into the new year
because it's new year willing to take on
risk but you also have to consider
everything going off macros so pulling
that aside that's a whole nother
discussion um but you know i think that
those those things kind of played a part
in terms of we've seen a lack of kind of
spot bid meanwhile you had
as we've talked about
the derivatives market position for more
upside really aggressively
and so you kind of have this underlying
you know uh you know
likelihood you know for some kind of
move like this and then friday night uh
the reason why it happened friday night
you know usually you see like you know
elon tweeting like some sustainability
flood or some kind of news driven event
that really you know gives price the
juice to really flush down and start
triggering that cascade of liquidations
um you know what actually happened was
just the fact that the books were really
really thin
and so if you're watching the order
books this is something that i don't pay
attention to extremely heavily but you
know i i
am in different group chats or talk to
different people who you know really pay
attention to this kind of thing and so
um
you know there
i got several messages saying hey look
you know the liquidity is really drying
up uh you know the bid ask spread is
widening um you know the books are just
getting really thin and so essentially
what this means is on the order on the
order book you have you know bids and
asks which are essentially orders saying
i you know i'm not willing to you know
buy or sell interact with the current
market price but you know i'll be a
willing seller at you know x price or
i'll be a willing buyer at x price below
and that's what i deem fair value for
bitcoin and where i'd be interested in
starting to average in a position
got it we saw all those bids and asks
almost completely disappear leading up
to this event so it was actually the the
least amount of liquidity since the move
uh before may and so what that meant is
that if if you were coming in looking to
trigger some kind of move like this um
you know it was very easy for you to
kind of uh you know
trigger this kind of cascading effect i
think it only it was like 8 000 bitcoin
really kind of triggered this move um
which you know usually isn't a whole lot
for you know the overall you know
bitcoin market and it can usually absorb
that really well but because there was
such a lack of um you know order orders
in the books that you know as soon as we
saw those spot orders hitting hitting
the market then that really kind of
moved the price down and started to
trigger that cascading effect and so
like
you know i know this is kind of a meme
that like oh whales manipulate the
market and whatever whether you want to
call it manipulation or whatever um you
know i think
i think this was honestly you know a
planned event i think you know someone
someone was looking at this and said hey
you know
the books are really thin we've got all
this oi to flush out you know we've been
in a regime of positive funding long
short ratios or at all-time highs uh you
know let's go ahead and just trigger
this thing right somebody's got to do
let's just rip the band-aid off um you
know you could easily go short trick or
the trickle that trigger the cascade
uh and then you know cash in big on some
kind of move like this um and so you
know i definitely think this was an
orchestrated thing in the sense that you
know someone saw an opportunity and took
the opportunity but at the same time you
know i i don't think it's something like
you should be outraged because whales
are manipulating the market i mean this
is just an opportunity that was there in
the same way that you know you see a lot
of shorts building up and um you know i
think the kind of people that are saying
like oh this is manipulation or would be
the same people not to complain if you
saw you know a large short you know
liquidation event because you know some
whale saw there was advantage just to
trigger shorts you know it's just uh
that was the setup that was that was
there at the time and i think someone
just took advantage of that
all right so i want to talk about what's
going on right now when we look at a lot
of these metrics um
you've put out uh the first chart for
today is this open interest dominance
and basically what you've done is you've
drawn this line here that's showing kind
of a resetting over and over again so
explain what open interest dominance
means and then what you're seeing here
with this chart
right so first of all let's just talk
about what open interest is so open
interest is all the total amount of all
the open contracts in the in the bitcoin
futures market
and specifically in this chart i'm
looking at the perpetual swap market
only um which it's not actually label
that i forgot to label it before i sent
the letter but this is looking at
specifically only the perpetual
futures open interest
and so
what this metric is essentially trying
to show you is how high open interest is
relative to market cap
because you know if if open interest is
at a 100 million dollars and you know
bitcoin's market cap is a billion
dollars that ma that matters you know a
lot less than you know if uh if open if
open interest is 100 million and
bitcoin's market cap is you know 150
million because it has a much larger
weight as a as a you know percentage of
what market cap is so it's it's more
it's more uh influenced by the
derivatives market and so whenever that
whenever that decreases or you see these
flushes that means that the market's now
driven more so by spot than derivatives
um and so when you when you look back at
this chart you'll see earlier this year
um heading into all-time highs uh in
kind of mid-may heading into i'm sorry
in mid april heading into may um we were
really high in terms of this metric so
you know open interest was really
mooning um we had all these traders you
know thinking okay bitcoin's going to
the moon on the leverage long they all
got wiped out in may um and then from
there we built up a lot more open
interest this time it was actually
shorts heading into uh the end of july
and so pomp this is something that you
know you and i were on top of at the
time we were watching funding go
negative as price was grinding higher we
were talking about the likelihood of a
short squeeze the week before we got a
large short squeeze off the lows we had
10 straight days off of off the lows
wiped out all that open interest that
was majority shorts
or aggressively shorts i should say um
and then we had another wipeout on that
failed break above 53k um and and part
of the reason behind that was that all
uh funding was really mooning and so
that's that's where you know we learned
that you also need to be paying
attention to the alt market as well um
because i think at the time
i'm going off on a little bit of tangent
here but i think at the time
people were saying well if bitcoin's
going to break out then i'll just go
ahead and front run the effect of you
know you could just go out on the risk
curve in long alts and so people were
all longing alts and you saw that
through funding but we were just you
know tunnel vision looking at bitcoin
and so
that that's what kind of triggered that
that event there um if funding was
relatively muted at the time for bitcoin
on that on that third flush
um above you know in september of this
year uh but
uh funding on alts was like 250 apr and
so
that kind of assisted in triggering a
flush there we wiped out a lot of the
open interest uh we moved down to about
40k uh kind of double bottomed before
moving higher and then most recently we
built up a lot more open interest um
we've we've kind of set this this
uh you know higher kind of zone over the
last couple weeks of of open interest
and we've just kind of been hanging out
there
and then recently this last week we
finally flushed that out back down to
the lowest point since may which means
that the market is is uh you know the
most spot driven uh or spot dominated
since may because now you know all the
leveraged guys that just got wiped out
are really hesitant to get back in the
market because they just got completely
obliterated especially like uh buy bit
which tends to be like a more retail
driven exchange by bit oh i got wiped
out by like 50 percent um and so you
know you're seeing that now now these
people are yeah absolutely obliterated
um now you're seeing that the market's a
lot more spot driven
okay now i want to talk about this
second one because there was a second
metric that i think you were watching
pretty aggressively here uh and this is
basically looking at the long short
ratio uh specifically around uh the
perpetual market and so describe a
little bit about what that means what is
the long short ratio in the purp market
uh and then why were you a little
cautious when you started to see what
was happening
so first of all i think it's important
to understand that i think there's a bit
of a misconception around this metric in
the sense that
it's not saying that there's more longs
than shorts which i know seems a little
confusing but there's there's a short
for every long and along for every short
so it's just a contract and someone's
taking the other side of that contract
and so what you really need to think
about is what what is the risk of the
people on both sides those contracts so
for example you know you can have a
retail ape on the long side that's you
know saying you know i think bitcoin is
going to go to the moon right and then
at the same at the same time you could
have a market maker on the other on the
other side of that contract and they may
be short the perp contract but they
could actually be long spot as well and
just be delta neutral because they're a
market maker so market makers are delta
neutral meaning that they have no
directional bias in the market they're
just providing liquidity and then they
get paid a fee by the exchanges so what
i'm saying is it's key to understand
that there's a long for every short is
short for every long it's just about
what is the risk that each sides of the
of that contractor holding
with that being said what the long short
ratio is showing here is the amount of
accounts that are net long versus net
short and so kind of the the idea behind
this is that when you have um you know
the majority of market participants that
are positioned a certain way
you're that likely means that you know
that's that's over tried you know
whenever you have something that's
consensus generally that the opposite
happens um and so we had we had an
all-time high in terms of this long
short ratio on binance which is the
largest uh you know largest exchange by
volume and open interest uh and so that
meant that you know retail was really
aggressively positioned for higher
prices without any kind of major flush
out or shake out event
and so that paired with some of the
other things we talked about also had me
really cautious but that that got wiped
out pretty substantially
during that move as well which which is
a good sign because now you've seen um
you know some of that kind of exuberance
or greed kind of flushed out of the
market
all right the last thing on the perps is
the funding rate across all exchanges uh
what are you seeing here uh in terms of
uh kind of negative or positive funding
rates
sure so first of all i know we talk
about this a fair amount but for maybe
anybody who doesn't know the funding
rate is based on premium when the
premium is the difference between the
perpetual contract price and the
weighted spot index price so it's
essentially a mechanism that
incentivizes market participants to keep
the perp contract pegged to the weighted
spot index price by paying out a funding
rate for taking the other side of the
trade so when funding is positive longs
are paying short and when funding is
negative shorts are paying longs so
funding is really useful in two ways in
my opinion so a when price is diverging
from funding so that just means when for
example price is dropping and funding is
rising or you know price is rising
funding is dropping and and b is when
there's a regime meaning kind of an
extended period of time when funding is
either uh rising uh or positive negative
or or mixed um and that also needs to be
paired with high open interest that
hasn't been flushed yet the reasoning
the reason i tag on that extra point
it's really crucial to understand
because if there's no open interest who
cares about the funding because you know
open interest doesn't have a major
impact on the market right now so for
example you know funding is is uh less
important right now than it was you know
call it a month or so ago just because
oh i got wiped out pretty heavily i mean
it's still important but it's not you
know as as important uh and then so two
examples of a so i said a was when when
price is diverging from funding b is
when there's a regime so two examples of
a were first of all when we when we
squeezed off the summer lows uh price
was moving up funding was dropping
especially on buybit
and then also another example would be
after the all-time high breakout last
month when price started grinding down
and funding was mooning so you know you
had that dislocation there um and then
this this this most recent flash was
more of an example of b so meaning you
know we had a prolonged kind of uh
regime of positive funding paired with
all the you know we talked about the
long short ratio as well as we were at
all-time highs um in both bcc and usd
terms nearly on on their perpetual open
interest as well as open interest
excluding uh cme
um and so
so going off of this kind of idea of
regimes
we talked about well actually i was on
the show last week um last week in the
newsletter i showed like this kind of
zoomed out view of um of all of the all
fundings of you know history since like
march 2020 and so do you just kind of
walk through this briefly
uh i won't like get into it too much but
so after after the march you know
liquidation cascade we were in a regime
of negative funding and we were prices
grinding up meaning traders were
essentially in disbelief which is you
know what you really want to see if your
bull um you know heading into kind of
the september area uh once we kind of if
you look at the chart you know in
september of last year we kind of this
plateau up on the on the price action so
we went up kind of plateaued out and
then we had this 20 20 uh move down on
that initial move up when we were
plateauing funding was mooning um it was
like the highest it had been all year
meaning that you know perpetrators were
saying oh you know we're going straight
to all time we're going straight to 20k
um you know you know this is it right
and so then
they inevitably kind of got flushed out
um and so
uh we we went from a regime of positive
funding then that got flushed out and
then after september after that 20-25
correction um in september of last year
we were in a mixed regime meaning that
we had both negative and positive and
majority negative and that's what you
really want to see if you're bulb as
well i mean
what you really really want to see is
just straight negative but you know
generally like uh if you're in the if
you're in the bitcoin market you're by
definition you know bullish on the
assets so generally um you know you're
going to see it you know mixed funding
at a minimum uh but that that's really
showing you uncertainty mixed funding is
showing you kind of uncertainty from
perpetrators or kind of lack of of you
know full just kind of like
uh you know
bullish outlook right versus you know
seeing funding really high so mixed
funding is saying you know oh we're kind
of unsure right uh you know we don't
know anymore after after after the
september flush oh we don't know anymore
if we're gonna go straight to all-time
highs and that that really you know kind
of put us in a favorable spot for this
disbelief rally
that we had into october of last year
led us into that all-time high breakout
and so what you want to see now that
we've we just talked about
over the last month and a half we've
been in a regime of just straight up
positive funding with no reset we
finally got that reset and what that
means is that um initially when we had
this liquidation move that the per by
definition the the price is going to be
below the spot price just because you
have for selling so you're always going
to see you're always going to see
negative funding on some kind of
liquidation move just because by
definition you know perp traders are
becoming for sellers during that cascade
the price is getting driven below the
spot price but we're we're where you're
really kind of going to get this gauge
is kind of in the day or two or you know
a week or two after uh and so the in in
the two days following that event we
we're straight negative um and then
since then we've seen it go negative
again briefly and we're still kind of
just flat um and so what what i'm what
i'm trying to get out here i know i'm
like i know i'm like kind of rambling
here but what do you want to see kind of
the tldr is that you want to see bitcoin
consolidate and carve out a regime of
mixed to negative funding similar to
what we had at the end of september so
what i'm saying is that you want to see
these perpetrators essentially unsure or
ideally in disbelief of you know some
kind of move that we would potentially
have to the upside eventually um you
know i'm not i'm not saying that you
know this this will happen for exactly
this amount of period of time i'm just
saying this is what this is what uh you
know would put us in a favorable
position for more upside if you're a
bull you want to see this kind of mixed
regime of funding moving forward along
with some consolidation
got it and so when you start to look at
the on-chain cost basis the the funding
rate i think for most people uh it's
interesting they understand it right uh
you're doing a great job explaining it
uh but to me this idea of on-chain cost
basis and are we above or below where
that is seems to be like a really really
important uh component and right now
we're sitting below this so first
describe what exactly is on chain cost
basis and then what what does it mean
when we're below it for a period of time
sure so for technical traders the way
you can think of this is a volume
weighted average price
but for anybody who's not technical it's
just looking at the average you know
price that investors bought in and
specifically we're looking at short-term
holders so these are entities who have
held their bitcoin for less than 155
days
and so we found that this this kind of
price level is really important in terms
of how bitcoin you know price action has
interacted with uh with it
um you know
what what we see is that whenever it
kind of retests that's generally a time
you want to buy when we're in kind of an
uptrend um i'm trying you know we'll
talk about this i guess at the end but i
i'm trying to kind of get away from this
uh concept of these binary bull and bear
markets and uh remind me to remind me to
talk about that at the end i don't want
to start like going off on a tangent
while i'm talking about this but i do
want to talk about that at the end of um
but yeah so whenever we're below it's
generally time to be cautious um and
then whenever you have these kind of so
when we break below you can have bearish
bias and then when we have these
underside failed retests that's when you
get that confirmation so you look at
2017 we bounced off this several times
uh we broke below after that blow off
top and then we got confirmation um when
we you know had this failed underside
retest aka dead cat bounce back up to
that uh on chain cost basis and got
rejected off of that i had three more
rejections uh headed in kind of the
depths of the bear when we finally broke
back above that that kind of signal that
we were coming out of the you know the
bottom of the bear market
had this kind of mini you know uh rally
into into like 14k uh in
2019 which was primarily driven by um
you know the plus token you know kind of
artificial lock up of coins uh moved
back down and we kind of just kind of
went sideways leading into the the covid
crash
finally broke back above and then we got
that confirmation so that confirmation
is really key
we got that confirmation in september of
last year after that move we just talked
about when we plateaued flush down 20 25
we retested that cost basis there and
then moved higher without retesting it
at all broke below in may so that's
where you would have you know ideally
wanted to want it to be risk off came
back broke above coming off of those
lows in about in like late august
retested almost a textbook reset at the
end of september of this year and most
recently we bounced off of this last
week but then this week we've now broken
back below and so to me you know this is
this is a signal of caution and so you
know i think um
as an analyst you know your job is to
really remain objective and pay
attention to what the market is telling
you rather than you know what you want
what you want to happen or what you hope
is going to happen and you know at the
time just being objective we've broken
below the short term holder cost basis
um it's you know it's time to be
cautious and you know all happily and
i'm not saying like i'm like a gigabyte
or like i'm insanely bearish i'm just
saying that you know i'm not a bull
until we reclaim this and that's at 53k
right now which also aligns with you
know the trillion dollar market cap
threshold for bitcoin as well as also a
pretty solid technical level as well uh
but you know until we reclaim that um
you know i remain to be kind of cautious
and um you know not definitely not
bullish uh you know
at least in kind of an extreme way um
and so you know for the bulls you
obviously want to see this reclaim
if this gets reclaimed then i'll happily
flip bullish again i'll say okay okay
guys the market has showed me that we've
now come back and seen strength um you
know i'll happily you know go by what
the market is telling me but right now
the market is telling me to be cautious
because we're below the short-term molar
cost basis
for the bears when you know bearish
confirmation would be
you know re-testing this from the
underside as you can see on the
left-hand side of the chart when we had
these failed underside re-tests
after 2017 heading into 2018 um you know
if you see a failed underside retest
that's confirmation that you really want
to be uh you know risk off um so you
know tldr as long as we're below 53k i'm
not bullish um if we can reclaim it i'll
happily you know flip bullish again uh
and then bearish confirmation would be
this failed underside retest
all right we only got a couple of
minutes here so last thing is supply
shock ratios what's going on there
there's a little bit of good news but
what what uh what are you seeing there
sure so um you know just some like you
know positive i guess uh some positivity
to leave you with uh it's just the fact
that you've seen a liquid supply
increasing which means that supply is
moving to entities who hold at least 75
percent of the coins that they take in
so you kind of think of these as uh the
strong-handed market participants and so
this is a lot different than what we saw
in may where you saw this completely you
know draw down um and so that to me
that's showing that you know you have
these kind of fundamental investors that
are coming in and locking up btc which
is a great sign uh but you know
again you know i'm just waiting to see
if we can reclaim 53k i think there's a
lot of different dynamics going on right
now we have you know on chain supply
dynamics look great uh but at the same
time we have macro you know there's a
lot of uncertainty there
you can also make an argument that q1
flows are going to be bullish uh because
you know it's a new year fresh p l's
risk hunger you know
we'll definitely see if that if that is
the case i think the first week of q1
will be really telling kind of judging
you know are we seeing strong flows or
not but you know i think like
what my buddy pintoshi calls this is
analysis paralysis right you're looking
at so many different things you know i
look at like order books on chain some
fundamental analysis macro t i mean i'm
looking at a bunch of different things
and so like you know lately i've kind of
been going through this process of kind
of synthesizing you know how i can how i
can you know really simplify my view on
the market and so for now i would say
that you know 53k is my line in the sand
if we reclaim that i'll you know go back
to being bullish uh but until then you
know i'm i'm cautious and then if we
have a failed underside re test then i
would flip bearish got it jojo what
questions you guys got hey well what's
going on man
um so mine would just be around the hash
rate real quick what are you thinking on
that i saw we just hit a new all-time
high roughly six or eight months i guess
after china banned uh after the china
ban what do you look at from an on-chain
metric perspective when it comes to that
yeah i mean i just look at uh hash rate
as well as you know difficulty just the
you know the basics um you know i think
i think hashtag coming back online
really just reflects the resiliency of
the bitcoin network right we had this
massive you know migration of miners out
of china they completely plug back it
online across the world in a completely
decentralized way no one coordinated it
right and it just shows you like you
know uh bitcoin is almost like a
starfish right you you chop off one of
the arms that's going to grow back too
right you know there's there's there's
uh you know it's just it's just so
resilient uh and you know this this has
just been a reflection of of that in my
opinion no centralized authority can can
shut bitcoin down um and you know it's
been it's been really impressive to see
you know how aggressive hash has come
back online now we're nearing all-time
highs and uh we had like eight
consecutive positive difficulty
adjustments was just another another way
of just reflecting that you know how
aggressive this has come back online um
you know one other thing on hashrate is
uh you can look at the hash ribbons when
it comes to price and that that's
looking at like two different moving
averages of hash so it's telling you
when we kind of come out of these minor
capitulation events if you're looking
for like a way to kind of correlate hash
with price but generally you know i just
look at hash and difficulty my bad to
cut you off joe no i was just saying i
like your analogy of the starfish
that's a good one john what questions
you got yeah so mine would be around new
addresses getting involved in bitcoin i
realized a few days ago we hit an
all-time high of 0.1 at a number of
addresses it was just under 4 million
that own or excuse me it was three point
two nine three point two nine million
that own point one bitcoin are you
seeing that in the data are they like
really making any difference here
no um you know this this just always
this always turns up you know it's a
great it's a great thing when you're
talking about you know being like a
long-term fundamental bitcoin investor
in the sense that you know you're seeing
adoption increase you know more more
addresses being opened but yeah i mean
in terms of like anything that
translates to price and it's pretty
pretty relevant to be honest um you know
you see this though um you know for like
the long-term guys i guess you might
find this interesting like over time you
see you know addresses as well as
entities which are forensically
clustered addresses you see you know the
balance of the little guys going just up
and to the right over time which shows
you know adoption over time it's just
increasing right um and you know the way
i think of that is like if if you're
familiar with like ray dalio's big debt
crisis he talks about like the the
long-term debt cycles and if you look at
that you know there's this line that
goes from the bottom left to the upper
right hand side and it's just
productivity and then overlaid you have
the you know long-term and short-term
debt cycles on top of that but when i
think of like what is that line that
really is that productivity line and
that framework that ray dalio has and
kind of applying that to bitcoin for the
bitcoin market that would be that is in
terms of you know just seeing these you
know constantly new users coming on the
network as well as when you just look at
the percentage of uh you know supply
that that the little guys hold so you
run the ratio of like total supply
divided by you know the amount held by
you know entities with less than 10
bitcoin or less than one bitcoin and you
either way you want to you know cut it
you see that trending up and to the
right only and that's not even
considering the fact that most of the
little guys use custody services so
like most of the most of the entities
that we see as whales are actually
custody solutions holding bitcoin for
like millions of people uh but my point
is just saying you know like that that
chart is is really bullish for long-term
investors in terms of showing just like
adoption increasing over time but has no
real effect on price and like any kind
of shorter intermediate term gotcha
all right man if you had to uh guess end
of veer you got a price prediction uh in
terms of uh the next three weeks what's
going to happen you think we could just
go sideways up down what's your thoughts
yeah i mean you know
i kind of just go back to what i said
about like
i think there's so many factors right
now and that it's easy to kind of get
caught up in different things oh well
unchanged supply looks strong macro is
really uncertain you know so i think
like the the best way to kind of combat
that is just setting really clear
invalidation points for yourself and
saying you know it's kind of speaking in
an if then format so saying if this
happens then i'll believe this if this
happens then i'll maintain this bias so
for me that that line in the scene is
53k gun to my head though you know i
think we just consolidate i think we're
just ranging uh i think we're going to
kind of consolidate here for a while
carve out kind of this regime of mixed
to negative funding maybe we you know
then end up coming out of this moving
higher you know in the next couple
months um but you know you just have to
adjust to you know what the market is
telling you and right now you know we're
definitely not you know kind of you know
strongly you know bullish like we were
back in august uh heading into that you
know big october we had uh you know for
now i think you just need to um you know
just set clear validations for for your
ideas well people are saying um i read
some some different articles about kind
of a 40k resistance what do you think
about that
um you know 43k was just a really strong
level uh you know from earlier this year
as well as like in september um you know
i think there's a fair chance we could
you know range between like 40 to 50. um
you know
i guess my
i would have to like show you the chart
because i'm not gonna be able to work
this well but i think we'd probably
range between like 40 and 50 and then we
could have some kind of like failed move
down to like 35 similar to what we saw
over the summer something like that i'm
just spitballing though but i mean 40 40
is a pretty strong level i i think that
you know we probably probably range
above that but you know we'll we'll
definitely see what happens but yeah 40s
a 40's a pretty strong level of support
i i would you know suspect that holds at
least if we were to go down there you
know and and you know test it at least
at least the first time that we retested
we'll see that probably hold the support
but
i mean i i'm just i'm kind of just a
crab market maximalist right now i think
we probably just go sideways and and you
know carve out this regime of you know
positive negative funding before you
know whatever happens next
crab market maximalist all right buddy
thank you so much anyone who's not
following will on twitter what are you
doing let's go
uh i'm gonna drop his uh twitter account
here in the chat make sure you go follow
him on twitter uh he's got the uh
newsletter as well he's creeping up on
500k
i told you 500k by end of the year let's
go will come on we got three we got 40k
followers well we need to get you
verified i saw you uh going at twitter
yeah you know man
you know i i mean i'm not gonna lie like
obviously you want to get verified right
but like at the same time
you know i i have people that i've
literally got scammed like like like you
know
jokes aside like one guy got scammed
like he might have just been like trying
to say this to scam me i don't know like
damn psyops but he said he got scammed
at like 150k and so like you know
regardless like i know people are
definitely like you know getting scammed
by these imposter accounts it's just i
just find it annoying quite frankly like
just knowing that like people are doing
that in my name you know but you know
what are you what are you gonna do i
reached out to twitter and did
everything i could so we'll see what
happens i guess i'll tell everyone right
now if someone if someone promises that
you send them one bitcoin they're gonna
send you two back it ain't coming back
all right buddy thank you so much for
doing this we're gonna see you again on
friday next week
all right man hey and for the people
listening be sure to check out uh pomp
game on my my
podcast that is true that is true
it will be it will be out tomorrow wait
till wait till the union finds out all
the [ __ ] i talked about them on the
podcast
we're not worried about you dude
all right we'll see you later well
thanks all right take it easy guys